I am Michael Rapaport with my man
friends I'm an admirer fan Kenyon Martin
former number one pick list in the NBA
that's an elite club Kraven small group
small cross small crew first pick of the
NBA J when you went up there the shake
David Stern fan this is pre Adam Silver
what did his hands feel like was he
nervous to shake your hand were you
nervous to shake you what do you
remember about that moment
oh I honestly I don't remember like too
much of it I was gone I was in days I
was crying and tears and you knew it was
coming though right like you had an idea
like you could hear it chips off yeah it
was new building be the first pick or
the second pick even when I would've
been happy with but there's nothing like
been the first pick so nah man it was a
it was also real man it was just when
the moments where you I'm saying it's in
history it's in history yeah I came over
me that day so that was the best day
well I mean it's a special special thing
that happened in a great career the big
three you're on the only undefeated team
trilogy you're coached by former bad boy
Rick Mahorn al Harrington the league's
been so much fun to cover I've been I've
been just like I've had out-of-body
experiences interviewing you guys dr.
Jay Rick Mahorn Gary Payton can't get a
word edgewise in to them I never can
never can what's been like the most fun
so far I was you the winning your team
chose the undefeated but you know what's
been the sort of like the most
surprising most fun thing about the
experience of being a part of the big
three let's cover things mr. fan in
action mr. fans coming out to support us
after not seeing a few guys for a few
years I'm showing up week one in
Brooklyn
16:17 powers are strong out there that's
been great every week but just having
that camaraderie again and some of the
guys been in the locker room and playing
cards with guys going to eat we're gonna
have stuff like that I'm guys career is
over with NBA and guys go their own
separate ways have families
business is whatever they have going on
and we don't see as much of each other
but now guys getting out of here now so
I think a lot of guys appreciate that
who have you been most impressed with
just as a former NBA player and as a
participant in the big three and a fan
yeah because people forget that you know
before you played pro before you played
at Cincinnati you're a fan who have you
been most impressed with you know
whether it's on your team or somebody
else you know I see them out there in
the big three um Chris Jackson aka might
move Abdul Rauf you were a little
skeptical yeah first I really thought he
was struggle I really thought he was
struggling this because it half quite
aspect to defend in and but he's moving
he's on he's using his hands well he's
defending he's holding his own and he's
giving people the business on the other
side of the ball he's tough guard and
they run a lot of picking roles for him
they put him in great situations to be
successful and he's playing well man is
he's helping his team rooms and it's
seven in one six and one or not he's
helping his team so you can only say
that he's he's the biggest surprise for
me and I'm pretty sure a lot of guys
going out there being disrespectful and
he tortured him hit him week in week out
so we treated him with respect and we
got the best of me game so so we'll see
the baby
he's definitely definitely been playing
well man are you are you surprised that
when you played in the league you were
intense when I'm sitting here
interviewing you for the Rich Eisen show
you're intense have you been surprised
about the intensity of the competition
because this week your team almost got
into it with the ghost ballers and it
was Cuttino
it was resolved Butler to show on season
and I was standing on the side of the
court ready to get Jeff Van Gundy I was
like a pain go any further and it pops
off I was willing to put my life on the
line to step in there breaker and and I
told you the beginning sees Isaac Kenyon
if it ever goes into the next level and
you see me please just remember that
don't see red on me I'm coming out here
like I didn't want to get dragged
but like were you surprised at the
attention I think the fans in the
beginning none of us knew what it was
going to be but the first jump old the
first game was like this no disrespect
to the great Harlem Globetrotters it
ain't a celebrity game the Zana they say
in a charity event dudes are playing
basketball
am I surprised now I'm not surprised at
all is is it's the this competitiveness
that guys played with for have alone
they played an MVA with or whatever
professional lead that they played in
you know for numerous years God's gonna
come and they're gonna bring it and that
ball goes up and and guys automatically
it's like smell blood kind of life so to
speak you know but I'm not surprising
like you said on last week I got a guy
Lou intense versus power power sorry
nobody but you get arms and we um well
we had to take it there in order to get
the best out of I'm saying because we're
gonna get everybody best shot I was
being undefeated we know we're gonna get
everybody dead shot and they came and
they gave us a best shot you think even
your best shot here and then we just had
halftime we had to go back to the
drawing board talk it over calm
ourselves down and stop doing the stuff
that we did in the first half to get
down 12 and we walk them down and should
have beat them by 15 first round NBA
pick Kenny Martin Michael Rapaport Rich
Eisen show Carmelo Anthony via former
teammate of yours in Denver you also
played for the New York Knicks Canyon
you know what's going on in the NBA give
it to me rough rugged and raw first of
all what was it like to be a teammate of
Carmelo on that Denver team you had
personality they had you they had Allen
Iverson at one point Carmelo Anthony JR
Smith what is it like to play with
Carmen Carmelo Anthony and how is this
going to unfold I know you're not a
fortune-teller but how is this going to
unfold with my New York Knicks um the
speaker Melo first I came to Denver
I'm Melo was still a kid he's 19 years
old maybe 21 Wow Denver that's crazy
yeah and I use a kid
so that was my Jen again and I called it
my youngin but now just seeing him grow
he's a hell of a competitor man he wants
to win he believes in his talent like he
should people are it comes across as
being kind of being selfish but he wants
to win he believes in this ability which
more people care their way than NBA be a
lot better stead of your new dog Knicks
ah
well in regards to Carl I mean if he
stays mother they don't want him here to
do it there it's a max man it's
definitely a mess now they bring in
different people in position of power to
make decisions and maybe they tell him
something different enticing the one to
stay moving forward maybe add in a few
pieces taking a few pieces away I don't
know but if he wants to go somewhere
else I don't like the Houston move
personally why there's only one
basketball and CP dribbles that thing
400 and sometimes a game and James
Harden ain't one to 130 so it's so
equally James NC and me tomorrow why do
you think he's saying like he said he
didn't want to go to Cleveland that's a
weird way this time her decided Miller's
mouth but just like the same thing in
Denver de Melo never came out and said
he didn't want to be in Denver right is
that the speculation be there right so
that's I feel like it's time to speak up
their time and this is one of those
times come out and say where do you want
to be he's being thank you so what was
less let me talk to him he's been a few
months but yeah he got here's a lot
going on so I try to give people a space
right when there's something like this
going on because everybody else is
called everybody wants his time his men
its interviews family friends he has
personal stuff going on business so I
just learned when I say more I called
him text him shooting the tags or
checking on your brother I think it it's
fine you don't respond whatever right
hanging but for him it should be about
basketball what's best for him in his
future move forward so that's what it is
and there's a few teams well I think he
can go help but it's only my opinion
well where would you say would be the
best situation right now basketball
while the alchemor wise I would say
Washington DC with the Wizards okay why
what would he add and how could you
think there's away I mean I want to put
you on the spot to play him because
there's mathematics contracts there's
Manning arithmetic that I can't do yeah
that people that's getting paid to do
those yeah I can't do that the other way
there's GM's and money people and people
on the books that they pan to figure
those kind of things out but you and
Washington yeah I just have a strong
minded point guard a strong wield point
guard and people who respect in general
wall got Bradley Beal over there
excellent to guard you got other piece
you got Gortat you got young pieces that
you can be able to move and a break here
Morris I think the Knicks take those
pieces back some other there's things
that you can do add a third
team but there's there's Washington
there's Portland there's other teams
that Melo can go to I think that could
help why do you think why I mean that
Washington idea seems good for Melo I
think there are pieces that they would
like why do you think that hasn't come
up I mean it's like I don't know maybe
it has maybe it hasn't maybe people not
looking at their maybe Scott Brooks
doesn't think Melo we're gonna be I have
no idea I have no idea right knows but
if it's about basketball it's about
winning I can't see it working in
Houston I agree with CP and James I
don't first and foremost I agree and
then you add Melo into that equation and
then Tony's system I just I just can't
see it working and maybe I'm maybe I'm
naive maybe to it I don't know but I
know when somebody dribbles the ball 400
sometimes a game there's not a lot of
going on with other people I agree
you know I grabbed rich 400 and some yes
well I think it's 450 something whatever
it is average yes
ain't your name you won this game he
does bad that game II know that's
average and he's not gonna change his
ways in the way he plays and now I I
agree can't change the spots on the
leopard and the stripes on his ebook
can't change his spots or the stripes on
his even Kenya Moore and Michael
Rapaport Rich Eisen show one of the big
storylines of the off season I mean it's
been like big ball or ballerina
offseason in the NBA the Kyrie Irving
situation me and you were in Cleveland
yes
Kenyon was like Kenya was the rational
one because I showed up in Cleveland
infamously with a broom and and I snuck
that behind your back and then I showed
up to gain five little plunger with a
plunger in Golden State and you said
you're not bringing that into the arena
and when Kenyon Martin is talking you
off the bridge you know you've got to
evolve you definitely go looking for
when I'm the rational one in this
relationship now I talk about LeBron I
have nothing but respect for him as a
basketball player Kyrie is one of my
favorites I love him I love his
disposition
this whole thing with him insisting
wanting or asking to be traded on a
basketball level to me is surprising now
my guestimation or you knew surprising
are you surprising are you are you not
surprised by him wanting out I yeah
surprise it is a few of the choice words
that I can think oh not yeah definitely
I did a damn mine
like why out is mine they crazy crazy
thing for him Nance for because wait is
it gonna get any better for him no it's
not no matter where he goes like where
is he gonna go like is he like if you
want to be the man somewhere like you
were demanding clean he's the man here
please like you were the man in cable
anyone in temperature you don't know me
right before the man got there he was
the man ran 30 games Frank if that right
so using somewhere else you you're gonna
win 30 games so what what what is
happening with Kyrie Irving he I don't
know curry I love him you know I know
his Godfather rod Strickland I mean how
could you not love the way he plays a
hell of a talent but it's not winning
basketball at anything but do you think
he cuz he's heard if he's all allegedly
heard that LeBron wants to leave
Cleveland after next season he wants to
get out before the fire sale I mean what
is going on with the NBA I listen if the
man leaves let him leave then you make
your decision right but right now you
been to three straight finals doesn't
get any better
yo where else you going to go where you
have that opportunity that's my thing
that opportunity again if you go
somewhere else okay if you chasing that
contract right the Supermax deal you
have to make all NBA team priority to
get that you didn't get anything even
why there's other guards out there if
you go to the west you're not gonna make
it over there neither right or are you
going so all this has been said they've
been tweeting subtweeting instagramming
you know hit the Rollie with the Rolly
store Tyrese laughing I'm making videos
yes you are I think come opening day
come training camp which is it's gonna
come quick assume it's October right it
starts in October mid September October
we'll get in October September September
how do these guys deal with each other
cuz I don't think a trades being done
because if it was gonna be done I think
would or no no you have to go he's gonna
eat you some little stuff I heard that
he said talking crazy so she's
so you don't think they're gonna meet up
in training camp I don't kid I don't
think so I think it's too far gone right
now right the summer stuff I heard
behind the scenes man is what he said
you recanted yes should I you know I you
know I've learned my things we hanging
out with you guys and and you know like
we we talked off camera we taught and
but you guys all as much as you could
like a player not like a player I've uh
learned and I've understood from being
around you guys when this thing about
the fraternity of the league like there
is a respect that you all have for your
peers whether you like them or some
bears sometimes but you're not going to
really throw anybody under a bus to a
certain put you you might say this that
and take a little bit further but in
general you don't you don't let it get
personal not tonight because it ain't
personal with me unless if I've had some
dealings with you yeah
but none of what I say it did the work
that we do right radio TV instead under
the personal right but it's not personal
at all I have an opinion I'm a voice it
strong opinions and I'm going to voice
them just like you do as well but I know
facts as well I chose not to disclose
everything that I know for personal
reasons right friendships and stuff like
that and and in respective reappears now
but is is there's something some guys
don't abide by but like you said you've
been around you learn the cold
oh yes nonsense and I'm gonna join it so
much in iron that you've been great man
we're just respecting what we're trying
to do when you coming along with us this
thing growing and it's been great from
the top to the bottom and you've been
doing a hell of a job all right I'm
gonna try to push Kenya Martin to the
limit and say something that he regrets
when we return Michael Rapaport guests
on so for the Rich Eisen so
Rich Eisen so stay tuned
[Music]
I came here from Dallas a lot of
controversy all field on the field
Dallas Cowboys are you feeling confident
about your Dallas Cowboys always
confident yeah you guys are a little
confident a little worried about our
defense missing four or five defensive
linemen from suspension we're worried
about the new DBS but I'm always wasn't
the bet I was 16 always willing to bet
our 16 on my boys now what do you think
about Zeke I hopefully Lee don't do
anything man
we need him but I like Alfred Morris I
like McFadden I'm saying hey I'm gonna
say that hold the fort down in case of
lead through some crazy move on but you
can keep his nose clean
yeah hire some people be around him in
Dallas man keep in my trouble um I think
if you do that man will be I moving
forward but I like Dax man I did
somebody got his head on still got 82
still got 82 yeah I think we're gonna be
iron man we got a tough schedule yes um
our fantasy football thing still on your
down
ain't changing Mike come on man you know
that you know they have earned the
Chango senior fantasy football analyst
like I'm not like playing games Kenyon
I'm with you hey we've been following
miss Ellen brothers now okay I'm with it
all right all right man welcome to the
terrordome hey I'm with ya hey listen I
told you make it light on yourself
double the thing I'm gonna look forward
to the most about it fantasy football is
because I didn't know you talk so much
during games
oh no when you're watching the game you
can't tell you can't see but you're you
you are definitely the biggest trash
talker yeah but doing like doing when
I'm only like people they will prefer me
on the court cuz you let's talk us on
this though all right then the bench
that kind of talk but on the [ __ ] how
it is listen you it's whatever
and you got a voice and it's Pacey every
loud and and it's provocative yeah let's
just say it's provocative it would call
a full language definitely man I try to
keep it clean they need to mic you up
because they've been my coaches on it
right we can't play anything it might
mandala supination to my clan I think
being a kami means none of the footage
man um yeah it was a few words are you
they product could apply to compare it
was good it was part of good content we
are back
Kenya morning Kmart two-man weaving once
again when you when you came into the
league number one pick you were coming
off a major leg injury a broken leg and
torn ligaments in my ankle so when that
happens how do you mentally prepare
yourself to bounce back and there's been
like a sort of you know a trend
especially with the bigger guys Joel
embiid
injury rookie season Ben Simmons Julius
Randle played one game rookie like what
would you tell these guys like how to
get for like Ben Simmons all this hype
like it's like we forgotten about him
because you know boom we never even seen
in place of army he doesn't even make it
to the court guys the kids coming in the
18 years old 19 years old how do they
get interest like that bones are not
fully developed a lot of wear and tear
early um pushing it pushing it in and
then I really for this grind if I was 22
when I came in I had played a lot of
college minutes a lot a lot of big-time
minutes in college before I got hurt no
mine was a freak accident just one of
those things bounce back from him and
played a lot of games since but a lot of
these kids bodies are not ready they
physically not ready they haven't been
different ways to having that grind
preparing the playing NBA you know
that's a grind you know so a lot of
these kids their careers at halt before
you get something at the beginning like
I said Ben Simmons oil and be playing as
a third year and he's still a rookie
right bye Destin presses right like
you're supposed to be like why not let
him stay in college for two more years
right but he's getting paid to sit on
the bench and do what right here and
he'd help for three years
like that's mind-blowing to me you know
if he was 21 when maybe his body would
be more developed huh installed playing
bass was it was like a senior some in
high school is crazy you you again you
were the number one
pick in your draft class so many guys
are coming out in my opinion as a fan
they're not developed at through early
and and and it's like you're rolling the
dice you get picking guys in the first
round and it's all potential sometimes
it pans out sometimes it doesn't pan out
it's it's to me you know like like last
year the Rookie of the Year was like we
were talking about this all throw things
like there is no rookie here like is it
going to be Joel and being paid 30 years
they gave it to the other kid but like
Brogdon was it was was the rookie crew
what do you think of this one and
dunking where these kids are not even
they're not even fully grown they
haven't even started growing a hair on
their face they're not finished with
puberty but there's a number one picks
and they're clearly not ready even this
kid on the Lakers or I think it's going
to be a good players like maybe he'll be
a good player in two or three years
Ingram yeah I mean it's just crazy and
do you think it's affecting the
competition of the league it's affected
the competition of the league it's
effecting the competition in college
basketball because the kids who these
five star four star guys did one and
done and you bring the next five stars
so they're not learn how to play and
then go into the NBA and they still
don't want to play so like you said at
two three maybe four years away maybe
they panned out maybe they don't you
know who knows what England will be
right now you seems it's gonna be pretty
good but you never know right maybe say
the ceiling you never know you know so
there were 185 underclassmen that
declared for the NBA Draft is passed
around 185 underclassmen right it's only
60 picks only 30 of those a guarantee
that's crazy
think about those numbers now so some of
these guys that came out will not hire
your hired agents can't go back to
school what did they do go overseas
playing the d-league never make never
have a shot at making it any mere how
would you change it as a vet as a guy
who did it as a guy who stayed is the
guy who got drafted at 22 like if you
were saying if you were advising Adam
Silver in the league and I know you're
not a player here you want these young
do different things their money as you
can but are you are you rolling the dice
on making your money as much as you can
by coming
when you're 19 years old I I said
there's not enough honest conversations
being had between who college coaches
players NBA scouts presidents GM's
relaying a message to agents college
coaches and the player to say you're not
ready you're not ready voters do put an
age limit I add to the age limit it's
tough to just say like you have a kid
right now like I think the kid Marvin
bag and he's about to be a senior in
high school right now right he's trying
to reclassify to go to college in my
opinion he is ready to play in the NBA
right now man
not too many there's not too many more
Kevin's with Kevin Garnett type in my
mom he's that good he's so he's going
into his senior year in high school he's
ready to play NBA right now huh a little
more fine-tuning but he is ready to play
name day right now he can do it right
there's not too many people that's doing
that right now that can be that right
and the conversations are not being had
that you're not ready in two years you
could possibly be ready right you know
just to take me fences I could have went
after my junior year and declared for
the NBA Draft the conversations had with
Bob Huggins gym in Boston it's Kenyan
where do you think Kenya will get
drafted high teens low twenties right on
its assessment right Bob Huggins are you
can go but I think you can do better I
think you can work on this to get here I
stay number one pick Player of the Year
unanimous pleiades not just players
unanimous player here go number one
honest assessment you're not ready this
is where you this is what you need to
work on right in order to get to where
you think you need to be those
conversations not being had well III
think something needs to change
and it's not to disrupt people's lives
matter they have the right to go earn a
living if you have a right to go fight
for your country you have a right to go
earn a living 18 years old I'm not
saying it right but not a lot of jobs in
America or in the world
that you can leave fresh out of high
school and your mentally physically
emotionally ready for whatever job it is
right what is the news anchor whether
it's garbage whatever it is there's
training that you have to go through
sideline reporter for the big three how
do you start off your mumbling I don't
know what now we'll finally join the
shine little machine but it took you
time right yeah so that it's the same
thing and I feel like at 18 if you're 18
17 18 trying to do this job your
vocabulary is not high and you're not
that good in hell hanger but yeah but
you don't sound like it a lot of light
goes into it but they're not just about
can you shoot or dribble right lot of
going to it Kenyon Martin I appreciate
it the big three were in Los Angeles at
the Staples Center this week but it's
gonna be fantastic I can't wait to see
you do you think let's keep it above the
belt
I really would no definitely I don't
want to have to jump in there and bring
anything I'm playing some close friends
this week so um it'll be fun
it should be fun I'm gonna drink some
life recovery water all right coconut
water all right are we going we're gonna
go out and do it all right
Kenya morning thank you for joining Rich
Eisen show stay tuned it ain't over till
the fat man sings you dig the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to